There's a lot of things that we can tell
you that we can't do anything about. For example, we
can tell you, you have a susceptibility for breast
cancer. But, can't tell you if you're going to get it.
We could tell you, per chance, that you have
a genetic predisposition for Huntington's Disease. And can't really do
much about that either. Would you want to know if
you had a genetic disorder that is incurable or would
you rather not know. The 23andMe website to find
out certain information you have to opt in, you have
to do like a double opt in and they kind of go, are you sure want to know eh
where do you guys follow on these categories and
Ginny, I'll start with you. I mean you sort of
mentioned the hazards previously, I mean, do you want
to know if you have an incurable disease or disorder.
>> There's a lot of cancer
in my family and because of that I, I assume that there's a greater chance
of me having cancer. And I guess, guess I would want to know if it were
a lethal situation. I would want to know,
not only to advocate and, and, and prepare
but to also prepare for death, and my
children. And, and everything that comes with that.
>> I think that if
I could take an action, I'd want to know. But I wouldn't
want to know that when I left the house. Today, that I was,
a car was going to cross the median line and hit me head
on and maybe I wouldn't leave the house, maybe that's something I could
[LAUGH].
>> It's one of those, sort of, paradoxes.
>> Right, for my genetic situation, I can do something
with that. So I do, I was happy to know.
>> And in your case what, what did you do?
>> Well for me finding out that I had
the BRCA2 mutation I immediately contacted the breast oncologist
to refer me to a genetic counselor.
The test was from 23andMe, and they
verified the test with another lab, just to be sure. And it was confirmed.
And the recommendation was to have an Oophorectomy.
>> That's when they remove your ovaries, right?
>> That's when they remove your ovaries.
And there's not that great a risk for ovarian cancer but it's
significant, and I did that. And the other recommendation is to,
see the breast oncologist twice a year for breast exam and to also have a
breast MRI and a mammogram. Once a year, and so, I'm taking that
action, and I'm hoping that at my age
of 70, that I can beat it.